[Music]
well ladies and gentlemen the lines have
been drawn and the free speech Wars are
upon us this battle between freedom of
expression and those who would quash it
in the name of tolerance has been
ramping up for quite some time now but
it has officially arrived into the
mainstream from gamergate to Ben
Affleck's gross and racist tirade -
trigger warnings and safe spaces on
college campuses to Hillary's deplorable
z' comment - punching Nazis and now to
the mayhem after Milo yu-na police tried
to speak at UC Berkeley the battle over
free speech is now front and center in
the American psyche some of us tried to
put out this fire before it got so
inflamed and I guess we failed and for
those of us who have been awake to what
was happening this whole time there's a
doubly interesting challenge for us now
not only do we have to continue our
fight for free speech and free
expression but we also have to try to
bring along all the new people who are
just now realizing how dire the
situation is as it bubbles into the
mainstream before I get into the Milo
situation I quickly want to share with
you my experience at two college
campuses in the last week last Friday I
spoke at Portland State University with
my friends and former guests of the
Reuben report christina hoff sommers and
peter Bogosian at first the local
anti-fascist group was gonna try to stop
us
I guess irony isn't their strong suit
but about a half hour before the event
their protest was cancelled I'm not
exactly sure why they canceled on us but
I'd like to believe that maybe just
maybe they suddenly realized that we
weren't the gate hating women hating
white nationalists that they said we
were on Facebook somehow though I doubt
this group did their actual research to
figure out that I'm gay and married
Christina's a feminist and Peter has a
Chinese daughter
none of those facts make us great people
by the way they just add a little
insight into the lunacy of what we're
dealing with here the fact that three
moderate speakers had to be escorted to
the venue by an armed guard is a sad
sign of the times but the four hundred
people who came to listen learn and
share their ID
really took part in something great a
few days later I spoke at UCLA with
Steve Simpson of the Iran Institute and
Fleming Rose the editor of the Danish
newspaper that published the Muhammad
cartoons back in 2005 once again free
speech was the topic and once again I'm
proud to say the conversation was civil
honest and most importantly engaging
what I realized more than anything else
over the course of these two
conversations is how starved young
people are not only for honest
conversation about difficult topics but
also to have their voices heard without
fear of being called bigoted racist and
the rest of the usual buzz words
ironically as we began our
question-and-answer portion of the
evening one of the first questions was
about what was happening that very
moment at the Miley innopolis event at
UC Berkeley so while we were having a
common insightful conversation at a
Southern California University there was
a university in Northern California
which was literally burning because
rioters decided that their moral
obligation to destroy public property
stopping someone from simply speaking
was more important than other people's
right to engage in freedom of expression
all this leads me to what happened last
week with Milo at UC Berkeley and the
long-term effects its gonna have on free
speech in America if you somehow missed
it around 200 rioters decided to destroy
public property break windows tear down
light posts and burn whatever they could
get their hands on all so that they
could stop Milo you da police'
bleached-blonde british gay man from
exercising his freedom of expression by
the way I do make the distinction
between protesters and rioters
protesters of course have the right to
stand outside and chant and show signs
and exercise their free speech just as
Milo is using his these people on the
other hand were rioters despite what
several mainstream media outlets said
and they were there to create violence
and wreak havoc they are fascists in the
name of anti-fascism I guess irony isn't
taught in fascism 101 of course anyone
paying attention should have seen this
violence coming a long time ago I did a
video a few weeks ago about how the left
has
did itself into a corner by calling
everyone else Nazis so they're obvious
next move was violent if you framed all
of your intellectual opponents as Nazis
then suddenly punching Nazis is fair
game
I saw a disturbing amount of public
people including comedians I used to
respect saying it was okay to punch
Richard Spencer the alt-right leader
because he's a Nazi or a white
nationalist or whatever it is that he is
and therein lies the rub of free speech
everyone seems to be for free speech
when it's easy to defend but you really
see who's for defending free speech when
it's hard and uncomfortable to do so and
of course all these faux brave people
are nothing more than virtue signaling
Twitter warriors if the threat of Nazis
is so great why are these people on
Twitter instead of outside with gangs of
Nazi hunters
whereas Brad Pitt when you need them and
is punching Nazis enough what about
bombing their cars or burning down their
homes when is it just too much and at
the same time who decides who a Nazi
actually is if we punch Nazis can we
punch the people who talk to Nazis one
of the tricks that the left is using is
that this definition of Nazi will
increasingly expand until everyone has
silenced themselves out of fear of
violence their game of using buzzwords
is losing and you guys watching this
video right now have a lot to do with
that so they're moving on to their next
phase which is violence and intimidation
putting the violence itself aside for
just a second just think how poorly
thought-out this tactic is if the goal
is to silence their opponents does
Richard Spencer see more influential or
less influential than when he got
punched does my lowly innopolis seem
more culturally relevant or less
culturally relevant than before these
rioters stopped him from speaking the
misguided authoritarians are actually
increasing support for the very ideas
they claim to hate my low supporters are
multiplying like gremlins in water to be
clear I like Milo he's a friend even
though we don't agree on everything and
the fact that I see so many people
saying I don't agree with him on
everything is also a symptom of how far
we've fallen as a society that protects
free speech who
your life do you agree with on
everything why would that ever need to
be said we're all flawed imperfect
people who are often ideologically
inconsistent on a day to day basis that
you don't agree with someone a hundred
percent should be the most obvious thing
ever
we are individuals not pre-programmed
robots at least not yet
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week and sitting down
with Fleming Rose who as I mentioned
spoke with me at UCLA last week Fleming
was the editor of the Danish newspaper
that published the Mohammed cartoons
back in 2005 his life and in some
respects the fate of Western
civilization was significantly altered
on that day over 200 people died in
riots around the Middle East after the
cartoons were published and Fleming's
life was turned upside down I taped this
interview with Fleming before I'm taping
this direct message right now and wanted
to add here that he's truly one of the
most decent genuine people I've ever met
he's a fervent supporter of free speech
and free expression and he's paid the
price for it both personally and
professionally he's in the thick of a
battle that was thrust upon him because
we live in an unjust world not because
he is unjust he lost friends in Paris in
the Charlie Hebdo Massacre and now
travels the world to show people how
precious free speech is but perhaps more
importantly how tenuous our precious
freedom really is let me be clear here
this situation is going to get worse as
it goes more mainstream the left is
going to continue to purge all of its
moderate voices until it eats itself
entirely Bill Maher who's been the
standard bearer of the left for the past
20 years in America now gets called a
bigot by the left I was actually in the
audience at real time this past week in
which Sam Harris made his return to the
show and he and bill discussed the need
for moderate voices in the Muslim world
while also blaming Trump for his
executive order on immigration and much
more of course the usual suspects came
out after to call them both Islamophobes
and the rest of the usual drivel
eventually this destructive force will
come after every dissenting voice there
is because leftism isn't based on
individual rights and
individual liberty it's based on
authoritarian control the left will come
for everyone even their hero Bernie
Sanders let's not forget he's a rich
white man with three houses the free
speech wars are upon us and unless you
are ready with the knowledge and passion
to fight it this battle will be lost
quickly the issue we now face is that
the masses are going to wake up to this
battle only now years after many of us
have been in the trenches fighting it
combined the slow expansion of who the
left deems to be a Nazi with a
hysterical media full of clickbait
journalism and we have a recipe that can
only lead to more violence the challenge
for the rest of us will be to continue
to build bridges even in places we
wouldn't have thought of before let them
keep demonizing the rest of us and
before they know it we'll have grown a
new Center rooted in free speech logic
and reason bigger than they could have
possibly imagined hmm maybe I shouldn't
have said that out loud
[Music]
you